hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
visualize more biomarkers and extract
more insights
moving from single marker ihc to
multiplex
if my name is christy jewell and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by altaview for more
information on our sponsor
please visit altaview.com now let's get
started
i would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type the amenity ask a
question box and click send
also please notice you can share this
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's
live event now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or you can report your problem by
clicking on the ask a question box
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credit
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right of your presentation window and
follow the process
to obtain your credits i would now like
to introduce today's presenters
scott lawrence associate scientist
cancer genomics research laboratory
division of cancer epidemiology and
genetics
ncifnlcr lidos biomedical research
and dr kateer patel associate director
biomarker strategy and applications
altiview
for complete biographies on our speakers
visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
welcome gentlemen you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction christy
and thanks to everyone for taking the
time to attend our webinar today
as we all know the tumor micro
environment is incredibly complex and is
characterized by complex immune
phenotypes
dynamic cell to cell interactions and
ever-changing tumor
evasion mechanisms further adding to
this complexity is the number of
different treatment strategies and
therapies that have been developed in
amino oncology field
this creates a significant challenge in
determining the right treatment for the
right patient at the right time
multiplex ihc is a tremendous tool to
help address this specific type of
problem
multiplexing allows for a deep
characterization of each unique tumor
micro environment
while maintaining spatial context the
biological insights that can be pulled
from this information is incredibly
powerful
and on that note i would like to
highlight a very simple yet elegant
example of this here we have a melanoma
that's been stained with our incitruplex
technology
what you're seeing is dappy in blue
granzyme b
in that green color you can see there in
the lower bark uh
lower of legend cd3 in red and sox10
melanoma tumor marker in a light blue
cyan color
within this melanoma we are capturing a
biological event visual
by visualizing cell cell interactions in
context while maintaining that spatial
resolution i mentioned earlier
i'm going to zoom into a very specific
region within the center of this image
here we can see the immune response with
a cytotoxic t cell
recognizing and preparing to attack in a
budding tumor cell
what you're actually visualizing in red
is the cd3 positive t cells
clustered around a group of sox10
positive melanoma cells
in the very center you can see that the
membranes of
the cd3 positive t cell that has
granzyme b
polarizing to the membrane to the lower
membrane side
abutting a sox10 positive tumor cell
what you're seeing is a cytotoxic t cell
recognizing preparing to attack
that specific tumor cell we can clearly
see the immune recognition demonstrated
by the alignment and flattening of these
two membranes
the ability to multiplex the numerous
markers some of which co-express on the
same cell
on the same slide allows us to visualize
this type of immune response and see
this immune recognition and reaction to
this particular tumor
that's a simple uh example of why
being able to multiplex within this
field of immuno oncology is incredibly
important
there are a variety of multiplexing
platforms that are currently available
in within the market there are many
different considerations to
evaluate when trying to decide on the
particular type of platform that is best
for
evaluating your own specific research
goals and needs
alta view has been really founded on a
foundation of evaluating all the
platforms that are currently available
in picking and choosing the best
features of all of them and adapting to
what the specific needs of our
researchers today in immuno oncology
feel that requiring
some of the key areas to consider when
looking at different platforms is
you know a high level of multiplexing be
able to specifically target
numerous markers and adjust the level of
plexing
quite easily we also want to be making
sure we can have whole slide imaging
we can see clear in a very uh defined
cell morphology we can visualize cell
the cell interactions
and really characterize any types of
immune infiltrations
and unique characteristics of the tumor
microenvironment
other considerations where i think many
other platforms fail to
to really to really establish a wider
breadth of
usage in the space is in workflow
compatibility
you want a workflow that is very simple
and can work with you know many pieces
of instrument that you already have
within your own laboratories
and then on top of that really from a
data deep dive perspective
you want to be able to identify complex
phenotypes and this requires the ability
to co
to visualize co-expressing and
co-localizing markers
as well as see different things like
differential expression
of certain types of functional markers
such as pdl one
to highlight some of the technology um
some of the technology advantages that
ultimate presents
we're showing a melanoma stained with
our
pd1 kit which has cd3 in red cd45 ro
in green and pd1 in that light blue cyan
color we've actually dropped off the
tumor marker in this case uh just to
allow for a little bit more clarity and
visualization
on this slide i'm really hoping for you
to be able to visualize the
co-localizations of some of these
markers
as well as seeing some of the
indications of dynamic range
from a qualitative sense
what i'm highlighting here are some
single positive cd3 positive t
cells here we're seeing some dual
positive cd3 and cd45 ro
memory t-cells and please keep in mind
when you're visualizing these in any of
these
analysis type softwares and tools you
can actually
get new colors when you stack two colors
on top of each other so when you have
red and green for example you get this
yellow color presenting a
co-localization of two markers
we're also seeing exhausted suppressor t
cells that are cd3 and pd1 positive here
and they're in that pink to purple color
and then we're also seeing triple
positive cells that are here in this
white color
one of the other things i'd also like to
highlight as you're kind of visualizing
and
walking yourself through this image
you'll see slides that you'll see cells
of different colors and different color
variations you'll see some that are more
orange
some that are more pink some that are
more purple that is very qualitative you
know kind of just your eye test
showing that there is a significant
dynamic range within the staining of our
assay here
that you can see low expressors to
medium expressors and high expressos
and now if you were to plug this into
any sort of standard analysis tool
you'd really be able to further dive
into that and really start to threshold
and sub
categorize these different ranges of
expression into new unique cell
populations
one of the other pieces i'd also like to
highlight was workflow that i had
mentioned earlier
so the ultimapure and multiview
technology can be run
uh automated on the bond rx or manually
and it's a very simple fast assay about
five and a half hours
whole slide imaging it can be done on
any whole slide imaging platform
it does not require any types of
spectral mixing so your basic hole slide
scanners are fully adaptable to this
platform
and image analysis is completely user
dependent this is really showing the
fact that we can
use a very we can have a very agnostic
approach to being able to deploy our
assay to a variety of research
laboratories
with a variety of different
configurations as far as workflow go
what we present here is a standard
workflow that's very amenable to
standard histopathological
workflows that we see in the clinic
today
so now to give you an overview of the
ultimaker assay itself
it is actually quite simple ultiview
uses antibodies that are conjugated to
unique single-stranded dna barcodes that
you can see there on the left
these unique dna barcodes are unique to
each individual antibody so each
antibody has its own unique dna
signature just like people do so cd4
would have its own signature
cd3 would have its own signature cd8
would have its own signature
this allows us to eliminate the need to
use any sort of secondary antibody which
helps eliminate things like
non-specific and background staining
this also allows us to use any species
of antibodies we see fit
they could be all of mouse rabbit
monoclonal does not matter species is
completely independent
the assay itself also allows us to do a
single cocktail antibody staining step
and also only utilizes a single antigen
retrieval step there are no rounds of
stripping antibodies off and re-staining
this is a single primary antibody
stating step that follow that that
immediately follows a single angiogen
retrieval step
once our primary antibodies have been
bound we actually go through an
amplification step
where we amplify the dna barcodes via
tandem repeat
this is this amplification is just the
application of that single strand of dna
so it's a single strand of dna that will
be amplified and this amplification
is linear and occurs at the same rate at
the same time for all targets that are
there
this is actually quite interesting
especially when we're discussing things
like dynamic range
this linear amplification allows us to
see a
wide variety of expression of you know
certain functional markers such as pdl
one
it allows us to differentiate low to
medium to high expressors because of
this linear application
in comparison when you're using
something like an hrp conjugate
that type of amplification is actually
quite is generally much more geometric
meaning it tends to hit saturation quite
quickly and that means
your medium to high or medium expressors
tend to hit saturation
quite easily and it's harder to decipher
or separate the range of expression
between those types of cells
now getting back to what we have here we
also have a single detection step
and our detection step is also quite
simple it's a simple dna hybridization
where we use complementary strands
called imaging strands that have floor
force conjugated to each one of them
that will go in and hybridize to their
specific dna
complementary standard dna barcode that
we were talking about earlier
we simply use a fitzy a tritzia sci-5x7
type of 4 scheme meaning we don't need
to do any special mixing because these
fluorophores are
very well isolated and do not have any
sort of spectral
overlap or bleed through and this allows
us to go ahead and visualize the targets
we have laid down
the initial step
and also another thing to consider with
this assay is that since we're not using
secondaries we're not providing any sort
of cova
we're not providing a technology that
causes any sort of covalent bounding or
kicking of things like such as you know
a teramite platform they do
it allows us to quite easily co-localize
numerous markers within even the same
cellular compartment at the same time
and this technology also allows for the
tissue to be
maintaining very very good tissue
quality and integrity
meaning that the athlete can be used for
other downstream types of analyses
we've had a number of customers that
have actually started stacking things
like ish
and fish and things like that after
running our fluorescence assay
as you can imagine only having a single
round advantage in retrieval keeps that
tissue quite well intact one of the
simpler things that we do on a regular
basis
is we run h and e's of the same slide
right so
many workflows that people have seen
working with fluorescence they'll
typically have
a serial section that is stained in h e
that is generally very very good for the
pathologist to go back and review
um pathologists are trained in bright
field there's
they're trained in pattern recognition
and sometimes fluorescence can be
a quite different uh platform to
interpret and read
so being able to get an hd of the exact
same slide
you're doing your fluorescence assay on
has been a tremendous asset
to our pathologist friends out there
that are adopting or you know
working with fluorescent-based assays
and just
and to kind of highlight that i want to
show is a very nice registration
of the fluorescence overlaid a an h
e
and there's nothing unique about this
protocol so we ran our standard
fluorescent assay and following that we
could actually just decouple flip the
side and run a standard h e protocol
to be able to get this functionality and
visualization done
so ultravio's current portfolio has been
designed around
really focusing on the major areas of
research immuno oncology today
that's allowed us to derive a number of
different kits that are specifically
designed to help answer specific
questions that
are generally generally faced by most
immuno oncologists in the market
as we see today
but that's something that we've quickly
learned is not not enough for what
people are currently doing
uh we have a services business that
currently runs up to eight plex assays
and it's expanded its
capabilities to a fixed 12 plex assay
our services business can
provide staining imaging as well as
analysis
and so those are all things you can feel
free to reach out to us afterwards and
discuss
but what we quickly found out is that
you know running standard four plex
assays in the field
it's something is leaving customers
wanting more
based upon the demands that we're seeing
from the field and our customers
and specifically with some of the help
from scott lawrence and his team over at
lydos
we've been able to start to deploy a
higher plex workflow to the field this
like i had mentioned before it was
standardly a services offering for all
of you but now we're expanding this
higher plex workflow to the field
allowing customers to run eight plex
panels in their own laboratories
and so quickly um and scott we'll touch
upon this later in his presentation
i'd like to walk you through how we
actually achieve an eight plex
without the need to do things like
spectral and mixing or stripping or
restaining of antibodies
so to start we still start with a single
d-wax and antigen retrieval step
we can still apply a single uh cocktail
of primary antibodies
and in this case we're actually going to
apply eight antibodies at the same time
versus four
we will also still follow that up with a
single amplification step where we
amplify all eight targets at the same
rate same time and again that's a linear
amplification
but when we come to visualization this
becomes a two-step process
in the first round we will actually go
ahead and image
four of the eight markers that are down
on the tissue
just in the same method that we
described before using a complementary
imaging strands with fluorophores
conjugated to them
we will acquire that image on the
fluorescent scanner and then we will run
through a process
called exchange where we do a mild
signal removal which dehybridizes those
imaging strands
and removes all that fluorescent signal
this leaves all those amplified dna
barcodes intact
even the ones we just visualized what we
will do
next is we'll actually come in with a
second set of imaging strands but these
imaging strands are
specific to the second set of markers we
did not visualize in the first round so
the second set of four we are still
using the same standard fitsy tritzy
sci-fi
size 7 fluorophores but this time
they're specific to a different set of
antibodies
once once we have those down we'll
actually do another round of imaging
and then we will co-register the two
images and fuse them into a single image
where we can begin to work our analysis
so you will have an eight plex
eight marker assay on a single slide
and with that i'd like to hand it over
to scott lawrence and he will be
touching on this as well as a lot of the
great work
him and his team have been undertaking
over the last year year and a half since
we've been working with him
thank you
okay great and hello and thanks kateer
for the great overview of ulta view
technology today i'll be discussing how
my lab utilizes three assays for
evaluating
protein expression on histological
slides as this
technology has grown from singleplex ihc
to the current state
of running 30 plus markers on a single
slide the scope
fidelity and resolution of data that can
be extracted has grown
we'll be taking a look at these
technologies and contrast them taking a
quick look at the strengths
and weaknesses of each but first we have
the requisite disclaimer slide to go
over
i'll just show that for a little bit
so with my group
um at mdpl we are a full service
histology lab that primarily supports
dceg researchers which is the division
of epidemiology and genetics as part of
the nci
with their pathology based studies it
was decided early on
to build the group to be fully digitally
integrated from the wet labs through
pathology
and data analysis for chromogenic
analysis
we provide routine hd staining for
manual pathology assessment
also we support singleplex and duplex
iht for marker analysis
we are excited to be working with
ultiview bringing multiplex amino
fluorescence
this year to the lab all these
technologies have their role in the lab
in general terms as we move from h e to
multiplex i f
we're able to get more data from each
slide but often sample quality needs to
be higher
and lower slide throughput should be
expected
image analysis in our lab is supported
by halo
along with r and tableau for data
analysis
while the trend for data density and
complexity
moves towards multiplex if and beyond
advances in deep learning
and ai analysis promises to yield more
data from all these technologies and is
something we're exploring
in future technologies
even with multiplex if assays capable of
generating data from eight plus markers
from a single slide there's still a role
for singleplex ihc
simply a singleplex ic is fast and
robust
here we have optimized our pdl1 assay
across
multiple clones and run concentrations
looking at the optical density and
positive counts
using our calibrator slide the analysis
is straightforward
and clearly one can see two clones
failed and move those closer to
solidifying our run conditions
to the right is a typical output from
our analysis software
and some of the metrics we generate when
we run a singleplex ihc
while singleplex ic excels for analyzing
a standalone marker
it isn't necessarily the best technology
to use when multiple markers
need to be considered
here we provide some archival images
that we are hopeful
to run spatial analysis across the
markers
but once we took a quick look we
realized that this set would not be
suitable
for multi-marker spatial analysis
studies
a quick glance at the image series notes
that multiple issues from incomplete
sections
section vibration artifact and
inconsistent background staining
alone these issues present their own
challenges and are further compounded
when trying to get associations between
markers when conserving running a
multi-marker analysis
with singleplex ihc the experiment
should be implemented with this
expectation
but even with the best expectation there
is a risk that subsequent
subsequent sections will be compromised
and may not be suitable for registration
and spatial analysis
consider minimizing the number of
sections need which will limit the
amount of markers that can be compared
it is also noteworthy how marker
expression can change from section to
section
in this data we wanted to see how the
masked
regions of ck positive denoted by red
staining
and how the marker expression within
here pdl1 with dav
would change the more distal we went
from the origin section
at section one one section apart rather
we do not see a large difference in
market expression roughly four percent
but by the time the sections are 20
apart
around 100 microns in total the tissue
composition
and alignment have largely shifted from
the origin section
and we see an increase in market area
difference
it might be hard to see but note that
the loss of the storm will track from
the annotated boundary
when sections are 20 apart large changes
in morphology
can certainly alter biomarker expression
when doing these focused region studies
with single-plex chromogenic ic
needle core biopsies have special
considerations when considering multiple
slides
as they tend to be thinner and with less
representative tissue content
we looked at a number of needle biopsies
to see if we could correlate
nucleic acid yields to tissue density
from these studies we looked at
how the tissue area changes at 10 and 20
sections away from the origin
section at 10 sections away
approximately 26 of the biopsies had an
area
difference of greater than 20 percent by
the time we were twenty sections away in
some cases more
sixty four percent of the core bodies
had a tissue area change of greater than
twenty percent
the large changes in frequency and
tissue area observed in the core
biopsies was attributed to the initial
biopsy size
and how the biopsy was oriented whether
flat or tilted
or whether fragmented or intact
due to the nature of neobiopsies it is
less likely that these would be suitable
for multi-markers single plex iot
studies that require spatial analysis
for this we move to running a duplex ihc
for the next study presented we
explicitly sought to run a serial
spatial analysis across eight markers
six of which are shown here
each analytical marker was paired with a
pan ck
as a duplex ic
after scanning the images were aligned
then registered
with analysis we created two data sets
the top one
which has pansy k on each side we were
able to create
to get each analytical markers
relationship with cytokeratin
including within outside and proximal 2.
on the bottom one we also generate a
spatial map
for all the analytical markers to
observe relationships between the cell
subpopulations
the primary advantage over singleplex ic
was to confidently analyze for our key
metric the market relationships to
cytokeratin
with less concern changes to tissue
morphology or drop sections
as an added benefit we are able to get
some interesting data on the spatial
orientation
between these markers ultimately
however a new population of cells gets
sampled at each section
preventing multi-marker single cell
phenotyping
as we'll get into the next slide
here is the same registered image stack
up close
while the sections are fairly close they
are not perfect
at close inspection we can see a
different population of cells being
sampled
with each section so it appears at least
two sections
represent have the same cell being
representative
by far most of them are not being
sampled
twice having the phenotyping marker pan
ck
here in a duplex ifc is helpful for
doing targeted region analysis
but for looking at single cell
phenotyping we need
a different technology and that's where
multiplex
if comes in
the multiplex if has a number of
advantages over the prior two
technologies key to this technology
at least for my group are the tissue
conservation and single cell phenotyping
with multiple markers
also preserving sample integrity when
considering orthogonal analysis such as
downstream
genomics is very useful but multiplex is
not without concerns
loss of morphological contact content
compared
with chromogenic acids can be an issue
this can be mitigated by registering an
hd slide
a multiplex if image or just having one
of them
as an adjacent section five throughput
can be a concern if the lab
lab runs 100 to thousands of slides
weekly
multiplex if prompts thoughtful
experimental design
due to the cost and the previously
mentioned throughput
it is not often practical to run every
slide possible and filter the
data later though cost issues are
debatable
since less slides are being used overall
another kind not listed here is the
increase in image file sizes
needing larger data storage large files
can take time to move
and storage can be limiting advances in
storage technology and or leveraging
cloud storage can be a loose solution
some groups
so here we ran a pilot study with old to
view
roughly a year ago using their i o pdl1
kit for this kit it stands for pdo1
cd68 cd8 and pan ck
along with dappy for the nuclei
using our analysis software we analyzed
our marker spatial relationships to
cytokeratin
as the top figure shows and we're able
to phenotype each cell and count the
population of phenotypes represented in
each core
expanding this analysis to the entire
tma
and associating available metadata we
developed a high level understanding of
multi-tumor
response with these critical markers we
explain
ex plan to expand testing to tma
specific to breast
and lung cancer to get a broader
understanding and assess assay
performance on these cancers
specifically
of course the tma does not fully depict
the heterogeneity
heterogeneity we'll see in a test
population
but the quality of the staining and
analysis possibilities
prompted us to move forward with old
view and putting together an apex panel
to run
in production
but before i get to the
apex panel and a preview of what that
looks like
i'd like to contrast conventional
multiplex iaf
with old view if as traditionally
getting into multiplex if was
challenging and cumbersome
to many groups so conventional if can
take months to get to production
shown is an example of a fourplex
arrangement to assess for background
staining
and signal crosstalk panels like this
can be rearranged multiple times during
optimization
and it can often be challenging to find
the optimum floor floor to target
and to balance marker expression
here is an example of how all
fluorophores are not
created equal with exposure held
constant
and both chi 67 primary and vise and
secondary anabolic conjugates run at the
same concentration
chisel detected with alexa 594 clearly
has a more higher signal to noise ratio
over alexa 405
additional signal application further
improves signal to noise
the amplified gamma h2x plus cy5 run at
1 10th of the non-amplified
concentration
outperforms as noted by the linear
intensity profiles
a clear strength and one of the main
reason we appreciate
appreciate ultimu's assay is the
approach to single enhancement
through linear amplification
this is critical for my group as we deal
with archival samples which can be
unpredictable at best
and often have issues with
autofluorescence
this is a plot of autofluorescence from
multiple tissues with multiple fixatives
and storage ages from source blocks
while the trend is the same starting
high in the 400 nanometer range and
diminishing towards 800 nanometers
the amplitude varies greatly a well
sword application strategy
can mitigate some of this by exposing
out the af
the autofluorescence
here the beta katina in orange is
amplified
and the other fluorophores were detected
without amplification
since the capture was quick enough in
the beta-catenin channel
the underlying red blood cell's
autofluorescence was not captured and
would not pose an issue
during analysis
on the last slide i look i present a
simplified model of the three assays
discussed today
and the corresponding analysis output we
generate from each
first yes the manual annotations could
address limitations with singleplex ihc
but for this purpose we are assuming
automated detection in targeted regions
with singleplex ihc we can expect
getting the number of cells that are
marker positive
and some spatial data between the cells
such as analyzing for cell clusters
for duplex ic we include all the data
from the singleplex ic
and now we have a phenotypic marker like
pan ck
that's lets us separate regions and
analyze content plus or minus the
phenotyping marker and proximity 2.
multiplex iaf allows us to do all of the
prior
but now adding the multi-marker
self-phenotyping
and the spatial relationships between
those cells and
one or more phenotyping markers
in the end all these athletes have their
place in the molecular pathology lab
it comes down to a question of balancing
the analytical need
the lab's infrastructure and support
samples
throughput and ultimately cost
an early preview here's an example of an
image from our apex multiplex
if we worked with ultravio help develop
the markers include cd3 cd4
cd8 cd68 box p3
pd1 pdl1 and pant cytokeratin
we plan to use this panel to assess the
tupelo micro environment on breast and
lung cancer samples
as shown here we will develop we will be
able to pull a number of distinct
cell phenotypes including
proximity data associated with each
the high resolution and fidelity of the
marker data is critical to our success
our success all of this will be run in
our production environment
and we are very much excited to be
partnering with ultaview
and look forward to collaborating more
in the future
with that i would like to thank all
these folks that made this possible
thank you for your time and now we will
open up to live questions
thank you scott and thank you couture
both for your informative presentations
now as scott mentioned we will now start
the live q a portion of our webinar
to our audience if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started we have so many
great questions already coming in
let's start with this one gentlemen can
you talk more
on the process to swap one or more
markers to make a custom aplex
such as novel targets clone selection
time to deliver
sure uh so this gets here uh thank you
christy for that question
and thank you to the uh everyone that
attended the webinar today um so with
that uh all of you can actually
swap in as many markers uh that are
novel or new
um that we need to um so even if the
proprietary target or marker we haven't
worked with in the past
we really have to just do a monoplex
optimization and then we can include it
into our assay
uh with you know any of the markers that
we've already kind of presented here
today
thank you katie our next question with
this technology
can you detect surface and intracellular
markers at the same time
yes we absolutely can i think if you
take a look at the end of
scott's presentation you can actually
see
a couple co-localizations of multiple
markers and different cellular
compartments such as looking at
you know t regs for example we have cd3
cd4 as surface markers but you're also
detecting fox p3 of the nuclear marker
as well
yeah and if this is kind of i could just
tag a little bit on that
in our experience we don't really have
too much of an issue
between looking at the different spaces
particularly with ffpe sections we had
some concern when we do
fresh cells and looking at cytoplasms
but in our experience with fmpe there
hasn't been an issue detecting them in
multiple locations
yeah and i think many of the challenges
most people typically face are usually
trying to detect multiple markers within
the same cellular
compartment so you know maybe trying to
look at one or you know one to
two to three markers rather within the
nucleus or two to three markers on the
cell surface
some other technologies typically run
into steric hindrance issues
but with our technology we do not really
see that problem
thank you can you have artifacts and
background signals sometimes
and if so how do you deal with it
so a quick point i can make on that is
you know we you know
with fluorescent iec and many a very
regular standard ihd protocols
uh you know background issues are always
something that pop up with our assay we
don't actually use any secondary
antibodies
so the amount of non-specific and
background signal that you typically see
with
standard primary secondary antibody type
stains
we eliminated quite a bit of that and
also by using fluorescence you have a
higher signal to background ratio
uh meaning that even if you do have very
slight or faint artifacts
uh that signal is generally so low it's
not being picked up by any analysis
algorithm
and it's something that you really
visually can't even pick up on compared
to the
uh the bright intensity of your positive
signal
yeah and um you know i concur you know
here i think if we look at that one
slide that i had with the um
station for the autofluorescence the
what we see is that with these
amplification technologies
um the signal can generally overcome a
lot of autofluorescence that's present
in the sample
and you know you're going to still have
issues with folds and
all those kind of things with artifacts
of sample handling and sectioning it's
kind of why we
always very much suggest good wet lab
procedures to generate the best quality
section samples
and images ultimately in the end for
data analysis but the technology
definitely
enhances the artifact mitigation
that we would see in a traditional
conventional multiplex iaf
how many slides can i stain and image in
a workday
so i'll comment for what we can do
internally um for you know through our
services
lab and what they've typically done with
our with our four plex assay they can
easily get up to 60 slides done in a day
um you know depending on what your
shifts look like you could even push
that number upwards to
close to 90. um for the higher plex
workflow
um you can definitely get 30 slides
completed in a day
as well but scott you know feel free to
comment on what your experience has been
in um
in your specific laboratory
yeah so um when we really
expect to launch the aplex uh this fall
it looks like we're going to be
processing um in production about 45
slides a day at full production
and that's including staining imaging
registering
and analysis our project
as it stands right now is about six to
eight hundred slides so
we'll definitely leveraging that that's
on one auto stainer we use the
lycobond max i think we're getting a
second one on boarded
as well so that might also improve our
throughput
um the imager we use is the zeiss axio
scan
v1 and that certainly has capacity to
support two
auto stainers so it's potential we can
get up to 90
ish slides a day but that's really
pushing it
so i think we were comfortable at 45 and
i think that's what we'll
likely target the aplex
now scott cause here can i mix and match
markers across the kit
so uh as of right now the kits are fixed
um
but you can see that we're kind of
coming out with this newer aplex
workflow that's going to be
you know formally released in the next
coming months uh but i'd stay tuned
until
uh about mid to early june where you'll
start to hear some more
offerings where those types of options
will become a little bit more readily
available for both of you
khatir are you considering 12 or more
plex to be possible
and routine in the future with ulta view
technology
we're always considering the higher
number of plex that's always a common
question we get from uh from the field
right now we're really focusing on
making the 12 places robust and
you know efficient as possible um it's
just as we have done with
the aplex and you know we've got the
apex to a place where it's readily uh
deployable to the field now
uh the 12 plex is you know being held
within our services
depart laboratory currently but we're
working on that technology to make it
more robust to be able to be field
deployable but
it's it's hard to say whether you know
what the what the next wave is going to
look like but we're always considering
being able to increase our plex
thank you now is there a problem with
eosin autoflorence
autofluorescence interference when
multiplexing on an
he slide great question
and i think maybe i wasn't as clear as i
should have been for that part but when
we actually run the esin
um you know the h e um of a multiplex
fluorescence slide we basically run our
multiplex fluorescent assay first
capture that image once you're satisfied
with that image and that image quality
then we would run the esn uh the h and e
sorry
afterwards and then acquire your bright
field image once you've actually stained
with eosin
and hematoxylin you really won't be able
to go back to your fluorescent
um aspect of the tissue and reimage it
so
it's really important that you capture
your fluorescent image the way you want
it
uh before you actually start the h and e
process
thank you katie now does the number of
markers used on a slide effect
downstream data analysis
for example is it better to do a few
markers on many slides or highly
multiplexed in one
so um i i can address this one right off
um
so it really kind of depends on what
your questions are what you know
your what your experimental design
and your hypothesis is um if you just
need to get
density of say cd3 cells um it really
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to
throw in
several markers tens of markers onto a
slide that just makes the
the process more cumbersome labor
intensive costly potentially
and you're really not getting an
advantage i'd say where you want to run
multiple markers in a high multiplex
situation is when you have specific
questions on these relationships between
uh the markers you're looking for do you
really need to look at rich
you know spatial relationships say pdl1
tumor cells and the
tumor microenvironment cd8 cells
etc adjacent to are you looking at
relationships between
these 31 same blood vessels and other
targets
that's when you start wanting to stack
the data on
each other and also you know if you're
trying to particular
you know a certain self phenotype as we
take a look in our eight plex i can get
this
here and you want to look at these
certain phenotypes then you're going to
need to do the
kind of high plex
single slide registration with all these
markers
for instance we're looking at exhausted
t cells for instance have this phenotype
here which is cd3 pdl1 or pd1 is rather
positive
so that's kind of when you want to put
the effort in to doing this large data
analysis
otherwise i would say that if you're
just looking at
t cell population then you might be
better off with a single plex ihc
thank you scott our next question
thank you very much gentlemen for this
great presentation how can we avoid
cross reactions between the same source
animal isolated monoclonal antibodies
now different antibodies might have
different affinities
so should we perform different antigen
retrieval protocols
at the same time for multi-staining
so i can take it i can take that
question um so we don't use secondary
antibodies uh we actually use the dna
barcodes amplify those and then come in
with complementary imaging strands
conjugated to fluorophores to actually
detect those primary antibodies that are
laid down and since we're not using
secondaries
and we're using those barcode conjugates
to do the detection
we can have any species of antibodies in
our primary antibody cocktail they can
be from
source from mouse or rabbit it does not
matter
and then what was the second part of
that question i apologize
no problem now different antibodies
might have different affinities
so should we perform different antigen
retrieval protocols at the same time for
multi-staining
so you know here at autoview we make
sure we optimize all our antibodies uh
for a ph9 antigen retrieval or er2 on
the bond
um and we haven't come across anything
yet um that
has required varying um ways of doing
antigen retrieval like a ph six or
something like that
most good high performance antibodies
that are on the market today
are usually amendable to using a ph9
antigen retrieval
so we've been able to standardize quite
regularly on that
good do you have antibody panels useful
for mouth tissue
great question that's something we're
always looking into
nothing commercially yet but through our
services uh laboratory we could put
together model specific panels
without issue
thank you how long can we expect the
fluorescence to be expressing on the
slides
and detectable
so that's another great question our
404s are incredibly stable
um you know if you're using a good fast
um whole side scanner that has minimal
you know that minimizes photo bleaching
and light exposure
to the slide itself we can get repeat
scans
of you know up to 100 acquisitions over
a six to 12 month period without any
problem
general storage is usually four degrees
in the dark but
i can say from my own experience i've
had fives that i've had in my own
my own bag for things like demos for
well over six months
just in the dark and they still perform
just fine with very minimal changes in
exposure time
thank you could hear now do you feel
scientists to help
show how to do this and help set up the
system
absolutely um i think it's a great
offering that we have here at ulta view
that
we always send out a field application
scientist for demos trainings and even
implementations uh we really want
customers to be successful with our
reagents i think it's something that the
field has generally struggled with that
sometimes
you know people are left to their own
devices without a lot of specific
guidance
when working with complex reagents and
complex assays so you know having
someone there that that's you know
well well trained in that space to walk
you through it and you know check out
the workflow
and infrastructure that you have on site
and to basically be able to help consult
you with these
projects and assays is something we
absolutely offer and
we take a lot of pride in doing that and
you know interacting with our customers
face to face
thank you kateer will multi-spectral
imaging
and unmixing enhance the results or is
it unnecessary
so um i could just talk from our
experience
we we did a little take a really quick
look or a close look at multi-spectrum
imaging and of course
technology and there's a lot of good
things about multi-spectrum imaging but
what some of the challenge with it is
very sensitive to the
uh i guess the expression of each marker
and it's in its
proximity to each other so one marker
can easily over balance another marker
and it makes it tough to balance so
there's a lot of optimization that needs
to be done
i'm sure coutier will talk a little bit
more about this but
with the old view technology each
channel is spectrally separated
sufficiently where you don't see the
spectra overlap
so unmixing is generally unnecessary
yeah that's a great point scott and uh
just to just add on to what you just
said there
um you know when you actually have to do
spectral and mixing it's
it's required to balance the fluorescent
signal for each one of the channels or
each one of your markers right so that
means
in order to to efficiently spectrally
unmix the image
so when you're turning up or turning
down channels to get them within a
specific range of exposures
um you're artificially kind of adjusting
the amount of signal that's truly coming
from the tissue or from the uh
the proteins that are present on that
slide um so that's what makes the
optimization quite difficult and it
actually kind of skews maybe what you're
observing from a biological perspective
and can
uh you know you're basically turning a
low expression to a brighter expresso
and a high expresso
and turning that down into like more of
a medium expresso just to be able to
unmix the image
um and the idea of being using spectral
and mixing is to eliminate that spectral
overlap and bleed through
fluorophores that are very close you
know we use
four fluorescent dyes that are well very
well spectrally isolated from each other
meaning you don't have to worry about
that crosstalk or bleed through from
channel to channel
and since we're not doing any sort of a
mixing the signal you're seeing
um from you know a pixel intensity
perspective is representative of what is
biologically happening within that
tissue
thank you both can this multiplex if be
applied on cytochemistry
so i have a a lot of experience doing a
multiplex app on
starter chemistry preps and
i haven't actually tried ultimate
technology on it so i would be curious
on what
um cathedral would say about it but in
my experience with multiplexifone
photochemistry
it's really highly depend on how the
samples are our cells rather are fixed
and
prepped as i think we had an earlier
question about
looking at the different cellular spaces
membrane cytoplasm nucleus
typically with cytochemistry or cell
preps
those membranes can be easily disrupted
and
can diminish membrane signal to get into
the nuclei and stand for nuclear signal
so there's a tricky balance and there's
kind of multiple fixation strategies
that
can be applied to get the best of both
worlds
but i can't speak specifically on the uh
ultimate plex for cytochemistry itself
yeah so from my perspective we haven't
had it we actually haven't tested that
yet
it's something that we've discussed
internally and it may be something that
we evaluate
at a later date but right now we don't
have any data to say how
successful we were not at stating those
types of samples
thank you now we have time for a few
more questions but i do want to remind
our audience that those questions that
we are unable to answer
live today and those that do come in
during the on demand period
they will be answered by our speakers
via the email address you provided
at the time of registration we do have
quite a few
questions that have come in and we for
sure will not be able to get to them
today
but they will be answered so let's
continue
can the ultimate assay be used on fresh
sections that have not been embedded in
paraffin
uh we don't test that internally
formally um but we have some customers
that are evaluating that right now as we
speak
um and it kind of speaks to the same
point scott had just made um you know
that they will require some fixation
processing um
in that you know working that out and
optimizing that is what would be
required to see if our assay would work
optimally there or not
um another consideration to take there
too is that most standard ihc
antibodies are derived against epitopes
that have
undergone specific types of fixation so
sometimes secondary sets of antibodies
need to be used in order to
optimally stain epitopes within fresh
frozen meaning
an antibody that works really well and
ffpe may not work
as well in fresh frozen
is there a trial and error required to
eliminate background
uh from our uh optimization perspective
not really um you know we really
optimize a primary antibody first and
then we really just need to
optimize the appropriate amount of
imaging strands
but that's pretty turn key at this point
for the amount of development we've done
on the numerous markers that we have
yeah and just the background here that
um so
you know our experience with uh the
ultimate institute versus conventional
is
a lot of that's been taken care of which
is really a
a large weight off of the lab trying to
as i mentioned optimize on it's very
difficult to get that and exclude
background and a noise
the turnkey solution the ultimate has
been tremendously helpful and
i think that's a very um a
strong advantage of the technology and
then in the cleaner application
which reduces a lot of that issue
yeah maybe maybe scott you could comment
on how much time it typically took your
lab
uh to develop a standard you know four
plex assay or something using some other
type of maybe chromogenic multiplex
or other force and platform sure yeah i
mean we so we do it chromogenic um
generally as i kind of mentioned in my
presentation we don't go
above two too much because then all
those uh the chromosomes can sort of
blend
and it gets more difficult to
deconvolute the
signal from one another but with
fluorescence um
of course the issue with fluorescence is
not just
optimized native by concentration you
also have that possibly the secondary
concentration
once you directly conjugate it but then
you also have very low signal
so it's really a balance of signal to
the affinity ability of the target
that you're looking at but then you also
have to balance it against which
channel that works best in relative to
your antibody
and then you have to look at according
to your on-prem equipment
to make sure it balances out and spec
that out properly
that process just to get set up is
pretty uh time-consuming
but i think in our experience we were
routinely six or eight months to get a
fourplex panel
iaf into production um and a significant
amount of effort on our team
thank you gentlemen and we'll wrap up
this final question what kind of
expertise is needed
to use your technology
so i think that's one of the beauties of
our technology um is that we know and it
kind of spins off of what scott was just
referring to is that we really uh
pre-optimize these assays for you
meaning the development and optimization
of each individual marker and then the
multiplex afterwards
is something that you do not need to do
and that in the past has required a lot
of expertise and a lot of time as scott
had mentioned
in order to do so so you know being able
to deliver pre-optimized kits is
something we can do fast and quick
and assuming the site has um you know
the proper infrastructure to do the
scanning and the scanning
um you know we can really get anybody up
and trained on how to run this essay
thank you both for this excellent q a
session do either of you have any final
comments for our audience
sure i just want to say thank you to
everybody for taking the time to
sit on this webinar today and i want to
say a big thank you to scott and the
lido's team
um you know as i mentioned before you
know they were really the impetus for us
to
develop this new aplex workflow for the
field you know as i said before
something that we had just kept as an
internal technology with our services
business but scott's been very much a
pioneer in the space
and him and his team have been an
absolute pleasure to work with and to
help us you know get us to the next
level as well
so thank you all and thank you scott
yep um thank you kateer and thank you
everyone else for taking time out and
listening to our
talk and stay safe everyone
thank you both and before we go i do
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
again we have quite a few questions we
were unable to answer so
those questions and additionally the
questions that are submitted during the
on-demand period
they will be addressed by our speakers
via the email address that you provided
during the time of registration
i'd like to once again thank scott
lawrence and dr kateer patel for their
time today and for their important
research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor ultavu for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast
can be viewed on demand and labrets will
alert you today via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
we thank you for joining us and we hope
to see you again soon
have a great day